[Music]
it's time to to hear that heartbreaking
story the dancing with the stars cast
teases most memorable year performances
it all goes down Monday night this is an
intense week how are you guys going to
handle this tell us what the dance is
gonna be like okay well my most
memorable year is kind of the lead-up to
2016 and we have a Viennese Waltz so
that'll be fun I think this week is very
special to Simone because it's the first
time that you could actually say
something that she's wanted to say for a
long time and we can't really give it
away too much why have you not been able
to say it in the past and there's just
no right words or anything like you can
just once you see the story you'll
understand I feel like the judges
critiques were always you know you need
to show more emotion and you need to do
more than the step and I feel like after
this week the judges will know why she
is the way she is and I hope this week
we can really open the doors and unravel
a lot about some oh I see you get
frustrated at means you care and I'm
very proud of where you've come in just
a week
what can you tell us about the most
memorable year that we're going to see
from you guys I'm a big fan of showing
who the person was before that that
adversity and who they are now and
showing that transition within the
number the words that I used to describe
her to Bonner was I want him to have
this dance therapy moment where he is
former self and his former bull-riding
self sort of tips his hat and accepts
and says you've got this now and moves
on to this next stage of his life that
doesn't really involve bull riding
because as much as he wants to go back
to it I don't know if that's ever going
to be a possibility for him being what
his has happened in his injuries and he
has to accept this new life that he has
to live